why is it default
okay
should be working now
hopefully folks can hear me now i don't
know why the settings keep changing
i don't know why that goes on
okay whoo
hey folks
uh hope you're doing well
all right
hey everybody
hey carowind gozer pirates
captain of crafts emily vacuum of
comments
homebody bruce simmons black cover
adeline rowan justin
cara i i won't catch everybody
mr nameless proposal
mr name was purposeless the seven that's
a unique one
knitting crochet tiger
logan good to see you all
i hope you are having
a nice day my mine's been
okay
i started the day by mowing the lawn
which like isn't my favorite thing to do
at the
best of times uh except it was a little
bit worse this time so
there was there was a thing encouraged
for vermont residents uh this year to
engage in um
no mo
may to not mow your lawns in the month
of may to give a better access to
flowers to the local bee population
which i did engage in um
[Music]
however
however that meant that mowing it today
which is technically still may but like
i've got a lot to do tomorrow so i did
it today
um
so i have a lawn mower that it it it you
know it fills up the bag with the
clippings normally i empty the bag twice
dealing with the whole on i emptied it
out four times just dealing with the
front portion of the lawn
yeah it was uh it was a lot and i had to
hit it with the weed whacker first
because the lawnmower couldn't handle
with how long it was
when's my surgery i'm not get i should
be i should clarify on that
um
facial hair removal
um that's not surgery it's not a
surgical procedure
um
so i i'm not getting a surgery i i don't
uh have a a date set up yet that's one
of the many things on my to-do list
tomorrow is to set up a consult with a
place that a friend of mine went to that
i feel comfortable using
so uh
i will be updating on that as it goes
along
happy semi-pride day
thank you supreme omega
avira passed all my assignments just
gotta do two makeup days this week oh
well that sounds very doable that's
great cara
happy pride month yes so soon
we've got pride and the queen's jubilee
nice i mean
i hope it's not the most offensive thing
in the world for me to say but like
the queen's ju the queen's jubilee
that's that's pretty gay
can we just can we just all like admit
that
uh i did the nomo man now my mower won't
cut the tall grass yeah like i said i
had to hit mine with the weed whacker
first
uh and then deal with it afterwards
oh it took a little bit of work it's my
birthday today 25 years old happy
birthday ms wicked wolf
i love your pendant thank you
i'm rather fond of this i i tend to wear
this
um
when i perform burlesque not necessarily
during the number but like during
intermission or after shows or if i'm
hosting if i'm hosting as vera because
when i host um
the green mountain cabaret shows i have
a different ho i have a hosting persona
called um snow peepers which snow is uh
snows is a slightly different
different can of worms than my normal on
stage persona
um
snow snow is a lot they are a lot that's
what snow is and like if you think i'm a
lot just like on my own and if you
imagine like i'm even more of a lot
performing burlesque
with that in mind i'm saying snow
is
a
lot
uh gaze in the jolly santa sense of the
word sure that works
i'm doing fine i've just found out
there's a nick fury tv movie from the
90s stars david hasselhoff as fury as
this camping cheesy as it sounds i did
know that existed i've never seen it but
i did know it existed
uh would the stream get demonetized if
you sing happy birthday i actually don't
think
that happy birthday is i think that's
gone public domain
um
excuse me
you'll have to forgive me for not
indulging you on that though i do wish
you a happy birthday but i don't want to
set a precedent of singing the full song
every time somebody has a birthday in
the chat because it's going to become
like the only thing the chat is very
quickly
anyone who is offended by that you
should probably ban from the chat caring
about the monarchy usually indicates
your right wing in the uk
and that's
that is fair
now i really want to see snow okay well
okay let me put it this way gozer
if you've ever seen an image of me on
stage with a
um
particularly obscene bulge
that's snow
so yeah that's uh that's that's where i
will
um
leave it at
with that
uh
am i a thrill seeker no not really
a little too
i'm slightly too introverted for that i
think that throws people off that like
i'm i'm kind of i'm kind of an
introverted extrovert
if that makes any sense probably not
um i can be incredibly extroverted if i
am in a situation which i'm comfortable
however
you can't just drop me into the middle
of a party with a bunch of people who i
don't know i'm not that kind of
extrovert
so
ah
did you hear what's been happening in
the recent owl house episodes i have not
heard do not tell me
i don't see them until they hit disney
plus do not tell me
topographic maverick today short story i
really liked it i do think it's miles
better than the original i've i've been
hearing good things about that one yeah
people hardly ever wish me a happy
birthday just because it's usually not
my birthday fair like that's fair
ambiverts is a thing yeah yeah that
tracks
what's the worst piece of doctor who
media day one
uh torchwood series one or the idiots
lantern doctor who series two
so
if you're asking which one if i could
throw one of them into a volcano i would
throw the idiot's lantern into the
volcano
that having been said if you're asking
me which is actually like
by a more objective measure removing my
personal reasons for detesting that uh
the idiots landed out of it day one is
probably a worse
just piece of art
because you know there are tiny bits of
the idiot's lantern which are kind of
cool which are kind of nice
um you know i mean i i will not bemoan
anyone who wants to cosplay uh rose's
outfit
uh from that but
day one is
that's
real bad it's real bad oh super chats
are coming in and i forgot to tell
people so
if you are new to the chat
you probably noticed i try and keep up
uh with the chat to the best of my
abilities
i make no promises about that however um
the only thing that guarantees i'm going
to see your comment is to do it as a
super chat which i will read and if it's
a question i will answer to the best of
my ability and of course you will get a
heart from me um the only other way is
if you are a
um
patreon supporter
the council of geeks discord which is a
patreon exclusive perk has a channel for
asking me questions on the live stream
and i'll be popping over to that in
about a half hour so but for right now
let's take a look at some of these super
chats
uh a.m paulson thank you so much
uh going to my first pride festival
uh as an out demi-romantic asexual and
am knitting an outfit so i will be a
walking ace flag
thanks for everything
wouldn't have figured out my sexuality
without you oh my goodness
oh that's wonderful i'm really really
happy for you
it's it's one of those things that like
i i get it it's not like i can't wrap my
head around it but it's funny to me
sometimes when people
you know say that watching me or or you
know myself on the vera wild channel or
what have you like helped them figure
themselves out when
like their um identity that they've
settled on is not one that i hold and i
just it makes it feel more like a
complete community that way in a way
um hope that makes sense
uh let's see john vinyls thank you so
much imagine if disney tried to do a
live action version of the owl house
i am pretty sure
i remember seeing this i hope i didn't
imagine it
but i'm pretty sure
um
bob chapek
said they were gonna stop with the
live-action remakes like the ones that
were already in production are gonna
finish because you know that's a sunk
cost issue
but um like i think after pinocchio
and maybe um
little mermaid that that might be it
um he see he said that they're probably
gonna stop doing that which honestly
they don't have that many more left to
do that i think people would be excited
about anyways but i'm i'm hoping so
the owl house i mean like the very
premise and the world of the owl house
it just lends itself to animation
it is so
ridiculous and lively and there's so
many like side gags just in the art
and you know just casually walking
around weird things that yeah
i i don't think it would ever be
anywhere near as good
in live action
aria c thank you so much for the super
chat do you think big finish will will
redeem jody woodkar's doctor like they
did for six and eight
um
so
let me think how i want to answer that i
think big finish will happily work with
her as soon as she uh
is available and willing to work with
them
i don't
like here's the thing
i don't know that they're that they're
going to go in on a mission to try and
redeem her the way they kind of deal
with the sixth doctor and the eighth
doctor
and i'm not sure that's necessarily a
healthy thing to go in but if they just
go in
wanting to tell really good stories for
the 13th doctor then
that's potentially a byproduct
regardless
so
you know we'll see how they end up
approaching it when that hopefully
eventually happens
jojo lopez thank you so much for the
super chat love you vera you're super
cool keep doing what you do thank you
i have no intention of stopping
cara thank you very much any tips for
creating a magic system i feel like i
got myself in too deep with my current
writing and i've only got 1.5 k words
okay so
the main thing to figure out at the
start if you're writing and you're
trying to create a magic system is
how rigid are the rules
because that is going to vastly impact
the amount of work that you have made
for yourself
so
broadly speaking there are soft magic
systems there are hard magic systems
hard magic systems have hard rules
that's basically the dnd approach
where like you have to have learned xyz
you have to have these components it has
to be these specific magic words or like
it doesn't create this it only affects
it like some spells will manipulate fire
but not create like if you're doing hard
magic that means that what you've
basically created is a science that
you're calling magic it has hard rules
fixed rules
and that tends to be a lot of work
depending on how heavily
magic enters into the story i mean
that's the other thing
while you may have to create a magic
system for your story
know how important it's going to be
um to for um
your story to actually have magic in
play like is it a background element or
do you actually have characters primary
characters using it because that is
probably going to impact things a
certain amount
because
like to put it simply
you are not even if you're doing a hard
magic system i'll get to soft magic in a
minute even if you're doing a hard magic
system
the whole thing about that is you don't
have to come up with a complete system
for everything possible with magic
if you know the story you're telling if
you at very least have an outline
figure out what magic you think is going
to come into play for the story work out
the rules for that don't worry about
anything else right now do that later if
you feel so inclined
there are some people who will tell you
that
it's somehow incomplete if you don't
like account for everything like you
have to have your whole world mapped out
even if the story only takes place in
this little bit and you know you have to
you know have these made up languages
and all your species figured out and
have rules for all your magic you don't
you don't some people do that and some
people like they get energized by doing
that but if you're struggling with that
just work
on what you know will actually appear
now for soft magic
it's way easier
and that is that um
soft magic basically means the rules are
squishy
so soft magic is something like
i think my personal favorite example is
the last unicorn the way magic works
there is very squishy
um and
uh there are even like some things kind
of in between like at least the extent
to which i've encountered magic in the
discworld books it's kind of almost like
mid-firmness where there do appear to be
rules um but a lot of the magic seems to
be more about nudging things than
controlling them
um at least as far as the which end of
magic goes i haven't dealt too much with
the wizards in the discworld stuff that
i've read but like you can find a
balance in between those things as well
so like with um
when i wrote my own novel
uh
you know i basically had both a heart
and a magic system in it
there's the elementals who are the
humans who exhibit a specific elemental
um
energy within them
that's a hard magic system it has firm
rules and what they're able to do with
it is actually very limited
um however i also have the fey
and the fae use very soft magic that i
have very
loose rules for and i preferred it that
way because i want the fade to be a
little bit tougher to nail down a little
bit less definable
by rules
so there's a lot of ways that you can go
at that
but honestly
if you are finding yourself not getting
very far in your story because you're
hung up on
how to get your magic system working
then just write the story and don't
worry about the magic system until you
come to a bit of the story where it
matters like basically deal with it on a
spell by spell basis as it comes up
because if you're finding yourself
struggling to just sit down um and sort
it all out ahead of time then don't try
and do that if that approach isn't
working for you then don't do it that
way
i went on for a bit with that
hey angus thank you very much
setting aside the uk which country would
you most like to visit cost not an issue
if i had a guide who spoke the language
i think maybe japan
because i think i think it would be
really interesting to go from the
contrast of a city like tokyo and then
to go out
you know sort of further out into the
more rural areas and experience that i
think i think that would be neat i think
that would be cool
uh john vinyls once again ever noticed
that lilo uh pilecki
is heavily coated as being autistic and
that loose noceta is heavily coated as
having hd having adhd
i have not watched
um lilo and stitch
in ages
so
i can't say that i noticed that about
lilo
as for loose yeah
yeah yeah loose
loose has a squirrel brain so
yeah that um
yeah that tracks magic can be very firm
yes it can caroline
yes indeed it can uh did you watch the
new chippendales rescue rangers movie i
have not i have not had the time
question where do you perform uh
burlesque sorry for the misspell i'm
going to be moving to chicago in a
couple days i would love to check out
my first show i mean i personally
perform with the green mountain cabaret
here in vermont
um and we perform mostly in burlington
and winooski so that's over on the west
uh
side of the
state uh sort of around lake champlain
um i'm sure chicago has
all kinds of options for burlesque i
have no doubt about that actually one of
the
one of the founders of the green
mountain cabaret alexa luthor she came
from from chicago
sorry my nose itches
so like there must be a decent scene out
there
the other one stitch turns 20 next month
oh great now i can feel even older
that was super helpful may have to
rewatch with my brains not so tired
thank you well i'm glad it was helpful
um
what's my favorite owl house episode and
character ah
i still like grom
as an episode
uh a lot
and i
honestly i think i like loose best have
i seen heart stopper i have not like
ah lots and lots and lots and lots of
people have have been encouraging me to
see heart stopper and i'm sure it's fine
but honestly i am
i am
real burnt out
of high school set things like i just i
don't i don't relate to high school
anymore that doesn't mean that there are
no good stories to set in a high school
or that age range but like
it's rare it's super like it's part of
why i'm having a real hard time getting
through stranger things season four
right now i hate the high school stuff i
hate it i hate it
i hate it it hurts to watch
and that's not me assuming that i would
hate heart supper but like the idea of
watching anything set in high school i
just i
i don't wanna
i just don't wanna and i'm sure it's
fine i'm sure it's great but
have you ever watched power rangers i
watched the first season of power
rangers and then i was kind of aged out
of it i was borderline when that first
season even happened
um will you be reviewing any more of the
time traveler's wife probably when it
finishes not episode by episode though
excuse me
uh thoughts on polyamory
oh boy so um
polyamory is
a lot to deal with i'm going to make i'm
going to give you the super short
version
i have
no issues and see a lot of appeal
in the
practice
of polyamory
i take a lot of issues with the
communities
of polyamory that i have encountered
and i feel that distinction is very
important i have no issue with it as a
practice
um i have a lot of friends who do
practice polyamory
but
the community that springs up around it
at least the ones again that i have
personally encountered
there's
there's a
lot that isn't great
in the community of polyamory regardless
of the practice
uh
see where was i
do you did you hear a big finisher doing
a fugitive doctor and sasha to one
master series i did hear that
um
oh
john vinyls once again uh what is it
with molly austria italian sapphic
kissing saving the world i mean
why shouldn't it save the world
ah
i can relate high school was a [ __ ]
nightmare for me the thing is high
school wasn't even that bad for me my
high school years were fine
i just can't here i think here's the
main disconnect i have with high school
at this point
is that and like this is accurate to the
experience of high school i'm not sold
that i don't remember this
but
kids in high school and characters in
high school when it comes to stories set
in high schools they think their
problems and their concerns are the
biggest deals in the world and in their
life that they will ever encounter
and i'm watching it going it's not
though
it's really not
none of this matters and it makes it
really hard for me to get invested in
the drama that's going on and like it's
why i'm still trying to power through
stranger things season four because i
know there is stuff that's gonna go on
that matters
but it's all the supernatural stuff and
all the high school garbage we have to
like every i won't i'm only a couple
episodes in but everything that has gone
on in the california setting
ah i hate it i hate it i hate it
oh
it's painful
bookworm of the fandoms thank you very
much for the super chat good news for me
i finally have a top surgery consult
schedule that's wonderful
don't have anything planned for pride
month though um
i wish uh i did hope you were good hope
you had a good may thank you so much
bookworks and
congratulations that's really really
wonderful to hear
uh
i agree about the high school women
that's why i can rewatch angel not buffy
that's why i can watch the original
versus the originals versus the vampire
diaries i haven't tried re-watching
buffy but i wouldn't be surprised if
that ends up being kind of the case for
me
so polyamory is like veganism in that
way
[Laughter]
um
that's not a terrible comparison
in terms of the um
the sense of superiority some seem to
have about being polyamorous
the uh evangelizing
of uh of their lifestyle
the uh shaping of one's life around it
although to be fair with veganism it
there's a practical need to have to
shape your life around it whereas with
polyamory they just tend to do that
um but yeah it's um
it's not a bad comparison
currently watching the hartnell era of
doctor who
i'm i'm gaining more of an appreciation
of that as i watch more of it have i
seen b stars on netflix i have not
um
i once criticized a
uh youtuber's video and in response he
told me to piss off and now my comments
don't show up on his video should i just
give up well if your comments don't show
up on his videos it's because he has
marked you as uh he's effectively
blocked you so this is something that i
have to do
a lot actually daily uh in my own
comments is to set people what it is
it's it's hide commenter and it's not
technically a block because it doesn't
prevent them from seeing my
channel they can still see it
and watch my stuff
but their comments don't show up anymore
so that's probably what this youtuber
did to you
so if you're trying to still reach out
to them
then yeah they basically cut you off
unless you create a new account to just
do that with and at that point i would
say it's not worth it
because clearly this person doesn't want
to doesn't want to have a conversation
so sorry give me one second checking
something
okay cool awesome oh jon vinyls the
super chat once again i was trying to
equip about the similarities between uh
enchanting grom fright and the finale of
shira
you know it is funny to me that um
uh uh owl house had the
had the grom episode which i really love
and shira has the princess prom
which i also really love
i'm really dreading the comments on your
spyfall rewatch regarding the question
boy the doctor outsmarts the master
which the fandom have gotten really
angry about yeah i'm not looking forward
to that discourse
i'm still gonna try and um
i'm still going to try and assess it as
fairly as i can like
i know what the discourse around it like
i kind of ran into this a little bit
less heated but i ran into this a little
bit with it takes you away where the
general fan discourse views the
character of eric in that the father
incredibly harshly and i don't think
they're wrong for doing so but i don't
view him as harshly as a lot of people
seem to
like especially if you're gonna make the
comparison to the idiot's lantern
but like i i had to try and approach
that
taking
my knowledge of the
uh fan reaction out of it other than to
acknowledge that i know this is what
people think and i'm gonna have to try
and address spyfall the same way
um i don't wanna go in already thinking
what i know because i haven't rewatched
it since it aired so
who honestly who knows
michael anderson doyle thank you so much
member for seven months happy to have it
the wizard by black sabbath plays over
the pa system as the amazing androgynous
android dharma struts down to the
council floor always happy to have you
oh supreme omega thank you very much
thoughts on identity crisis
whoo because i feel it had a negative
effect leading to the new 52 for me tim
drake never recovered after they killed
off his dad i
okay this is where i'm gonna allow
myself uh one swear per stream i [ __ ]
hate identity crisis
for multiple reasons
firstly
it
suffers from the problem that watchmen
avoided
which was that if you don't know
alan moore's watchman was originally
conceived
as a vehicle for a bunch of characters
that dc had acquired from charlton
comics so this was characters like blue
beetle the question
um
captain adam and a handful of others
so
when alan moore pitched his his planned
story
what the editors told him was we love
this pitch but we can't let you use
these characters because it ruins these
characters and we basically won't be
able to do anything fun with them after
this because this is too dark so can you
make original characters they can be
analogs and they are like pretty thin
ones if you know the characters he's
basing them on
and then we got watchmen
i feel very strongly identity crisis
really should have been
a similar thing it should have been done
with analogs because the stain that it
leaves
on
the dc universe as a whole and the
characters involved specifically
was not worth the story being told
and as a mystery
it's [ __ ]
i said i would only swear once i'm
swearing a little more here it's a lousy
mystery
because it has an answer
that is not
one that could be reasonably figured out
from clues
and also just disregards the
investigation process that went on
before
once you find out what actually happened
you realize the things that they did to
try and investigate should have
uncovered some of this stuff
it's not a well-written mystery
it
severely severely taints all the
characters involved it is
needlessly brutal the word the absolute
worst thing about it is the stuff that
goes on with dr light
and with the background in particular
with sue dibny now it's already screwed
up
because of what it did to sue dibny in
the first place
and
it's just cruel
and it it also feeds into this whole
thing that comics have where
there cannot be
happy stable couples
dc has this bad marvel's honestly not
only slightly better than them they
comment superhero comics in general do
this a lot so it feeds into that by
destroying
brutally one of the only long-term
stable couples that was still around
in dc
but then it adds this entire backstory
this entire backstory involving
some of the worst sexual assault
that can be enacted against a person
and the impact that that has on the
actual supposed mystery that this whole
thing is supposed to be
is zero
that entire end of the story
has nothing
to do
with what the actual plot is supposed to
be
it is needless
edgelord
cruel
nonsense
and i deeply hate it
and i really really really hate
um
the fact that it seemed to have
completely reset the mood
for what dc was going to be going
forward
people can complain about the new 52 all
they want i think the direction of dc
was locked in
with the release of identity crisis and
for the worse
identity crisis is terrible
and its
impact
is
nothing but destructive
it was a it was
an awful piece of work
that had
a staggering amount of influence that i
think we're still seeing and still
feeling
and it's a real shame
okay
that's uh
let's find a lighter topic if we can do
you like horror
that's a much lighter topic uh my
relationship with horror is that
i like some of the ephemera and the
trappings of horror there aren't that
many actual horror stories that i like
though i think it's a big part of why i
like guillermo del toro because his
stuff is dripping in
horror iconography but his
not that many of his movies would be
accurately described as horror movies
uh i've never seen or heard of inside
number nine but i looked up your reviews
anyway because it fascinates me when
credits dislike something
others love which episode was the one
you dislike there's a number of episodes
i didn't like about it the one that
pissed everybody off
was what is it a silent night something
like that whatever whatever the almost
dialogue free episode was from series
one
i didn't really like that and people
came at me for that
people
really really got the knives out over
the fact that i did not like that
episode
so
and here's the thing
i i didn't know this
i didn't know that this uh fan base for
that show was the way it was if i'd
known i never would have reviewed it
honestly
i had it recommended to me as a as a
kind of um
a non-sci-fi
um
sort of similar to
black mirror kind of thing because i
think i just i just finished up
my black mirror reviews i caught up on
that at the time
and people were pushing me to try inside
number nine and i tried it and i liked
some of it i didn't like other of it but
i did no research into it before
watching it
so i didn't know that i was stepping on
what to some people was a sacred cow
and i still get hateful comments on
those videos that one especially
ed and i will i will not i will
definitely not ever review inside number
nine again i probably won't even watch
it again that is my primary example of a
case where the fandom
turned me off the property completely
because it basically led me in a
position where if these are the kind of
people who like this show
i don't
i don't want to be counted among you
ever
it wasn't fun it wasn't pleasant and it
completely shut me off a thing that
honestly i might have enjoyed i might
have kept enjoying there were parts of
it i did in fact enjoy in that first
series
but um i'll never talk about it again
jon vinyls thank you very much why do
you think the characters in watchmen
doing terrible things it works better
than identity crisis for me the
characters in watchmen benefit from
having moments of humanity well part of
it's that but the other part of it is
those
part of the reason those characters have
moments of humanity is because despite
being analogs they were characters who
had to be created from whole cloth so
they had to be built up and created and
brought forth to the reader from the
ground up in that story
now in identity crisis they didn't have
to because of the fact that these were
the pre-existing characters which is
part of what the problem is
so within the confines of that story
it um
it is not uh required to show their
humanity because like you know batman
you know why batman's a good guy you
know why wonder woman's a hero like you
know super you know all this stuff we
don't have to cover it in this story so
within the confines of the story makes
the story weaker because they don't have
to cover that now normally
normally that's a benefit of
long-running serialized storytelling
like superhero comic books
where you don't have to cover the basics
every single story
but in something like this something
that is this
damaging
to the characters involved it becomes
what is normally a strength becomes a
detriment and it makes the whole thing
worse
uh john vinyls once again and alan moore
didn't excuse their actions yeah that's
true too
what are my thoughts on doctor who you
never seem to talk about on your channel
i know i should get around to that
sometime
uh captain omni thank you very much
stuff like identity crisis are why i do
like the multiverse for instance marvel
squadron supreme essentially the jla but
like watchmen
different i
here's that like i do make the
distinction between multiverses and
simply having out of canon stories cause
like i have no problem with out of canon
stories or what if stories or else world
stories but when you start building a
structure under which here's the
multiverse in which they all exist i'm
like that is deeply unnecessary that
that overcomplicates something that
doesn't need it and like i'm not saying
that um
you know it it
never yields decent stories but not
anything i'm interested in 99 times out
of a hundred
what's worse beavis and butthead are
dumb and dumber i never really watched
much beavis and butthead so i couldn't
tell you do i like spaceballs and galaxy
quests yeah i enjoy both of those
um
all my uni stuff is submitted and all my
film projects are uh for the year are
uploaded i can finally relax i'm bored
already
close to 60k subscribers ms wicked wolf
i've been close to 50k subscribers for a
year
like my growth on this channel has
plateaued for a while it has been at a
crawl i had a i had a little bit of a
boost
earlier in the year
um largely on the back of the video i
did on
ezra miller
but
like
i don't
i don't worry about the channel growth
too much and like let's not say i
wouldn't like the channel to grow i
would love the channel to grow but i
don't worry about it because
the honestly the algorithm doesn't like
me
it it has almost never liked me
and
most um
most youtubers i follow even ones with
fewer subscribers than me you know if
they're doing decently at all they've
had at least one video go like proper
viral like million views
i never have the algorithm does not
actually like me as much as people who
don't want to see my face [ __ ] about it
in my comments who the hell is this
freak
the algorithm does not actually like me
can i recommend you a show i just
finished peaky blinders i want to watch
a new one well because i don't know
peaky blinders i don't know what i could
recommend instead of it i do however
need to take a very quick bio break i
will be right back i thought i could
hold it till the end of stream i can't
i'll be right back
okay
have i seen doctor strange too yet i
want to ask a quick question i have seen
it my review is up in the break room of
geeks that went up i think same weekend
it came out
oh
let's see
spironolactone getting diverted yeah
yeah it uh it does that
let's see
algorithm has been shown it's been shown
to be extremely transphobic well yeah
like i
forget how many years ago it was now
[Music]
there was a period during which
uh
every single video that i put up on
uh youtube would be automatically
flagged as not uh advertiser friendly
and would have limited um
limited monetization
uh that started on the vera wild channel
uh and it actually happened on council
of geeks as well
uh
possibly because they matched the ip
addresses possibly because facial
recognition realized i was the same
person i actually wasn't out as vera at
the time
um
back when this happened so
you know it's uh
youtube has as
this is my living but it's the site has
never been
especially kind to me
just in time to check the discord oh i
will do that oh my goodness
it's her
eternal sailor hufflepuff my goodness
that wow
thank you
very much for that super chat
whoo
do you not like the concept of the chime
the timeless child or just because it
made the doctor too important
i liked it because it gave an origin for
the time lords and explained how they
can regenerate but it annoyed me to know
end that they made the doctor the reason
behind it all so
i just like the timeless child for
multiple reasons
the first is i'm
personally of the opinion
that it doesn't matter how the time
lords can regenerate and that is not a
question that ever needs to be answered
because the answer doesn't matter they
do they can they've been doing it
how why what's the basic
it doesn't matter like it truly does not
matter
i cannot think of any way in which the
story uh of the doctor or the time lords
is actually impacted by knowing where
rich excuse me where regeneration comes
from it doesn't matter where it comes
from it just doesn't so it's answering a
question that i don't think there's any
value in uh answering in the first place
that's part of it
i would have disliked it less
had the timeless child been literally
anyone else
other than the doctor
if it had been the master if it had been
wrastlin if it had been oh my god if it
had been romana
anybody
anybody other than the doctor
because
the doctor should not be the single most
important being in the universe
they just shouldn't
and that's what this does it means that
the only reason the time lords have
regeneration at all is because of the
doctor and that's
ah not like if that hadn't been the case
if the time a child had been literally
anyone else
i still wouldn't think it was a good
idea
but i ultimately probably wouldn't care
because like i said
it's like i would still consider a
pointless and a waste of time
but like
i don't feel i don't feel it's damaging
to lore to have the timeless child be a
thing i just think it
ruins part of what i love about the
doctor
to make the doctor this freaking
important and it's very
it's very fan ficky
it just it just kind of is
anyways i gotta hop over to the discord
um
i will be back oh hang on i saw one
question i'm gonna answer do i do i have
any close religious friends if so how
did they react to you coming out i do
but all my close religious friends uh
are either queer or have queer people in
their family so i don't have any close
friends who are religious in a way that
is exclusionary towards queer people so
my coming out had
zero impact okay popping over to the
discord whoa we got a lot of stuff in
here tonight okay
uh it's kind of silly but i'm excited
for pride this year and i uh and i know
i won't go to any events i don't think
that's silly i think pride is something
worth getting
excited about
i'm planning to go to a pride event in
my hometown if all goes well well
fingers crossed
pride march here on the 9th of june hope
you're able to make it if you desire to
go i wish i could watch but i'm going to
conquer to see my sister and we're going
to burlington tomorrow oh
my neck of the woods
have fun
okay what do we got here
so your laser hair removal do they do it
all in one go or do they or do you have
to go in for multiple sessions
uh also i feel bad i didn't help with
that but the fundraiser happened
while i was drunk and not asleep but
still sorry you don't have to apologize
um it is going to be a multiple session
thing
um i need to what i need to do is i need
to set up a consultation because i need
to figure we need to figure out if it
just laser is going to be enough i might
need electrolysis on some of my hairs as
well because i'm at an age where some of
the hard coarse hairs that i don't want
to be dealing with anymore are not dark
enough
to
be picked up by laser because
i have white hair on my face in some
places
uh have you seen the british movie pride
i have not i've had it recommended to me
it might even be on my um
on my catch-up list for commission
reviews i should check that but no i
haven't seen it yet
when someone asks you for your advice
about coming out does the answer you
give very much depending on where they
live and how safe queer people
uh are there
like if someone asked you about coming
out as trans would you give a different
answer depending on if they lived in
kentucky or iceland
short answer yes um my concern is
honestly usually more about their
their much more immediate surroundings
so like if they are living with anyone
who might
not be uh supportive or who might reject
them
but yes your
my answer to that is going to vary a lot
depending on your living situation
because i don't
while i want everybody
everybody to be able to come out and be
themselves the sad reality is that
it's not always safe to do so
and sometimes you need to get yourself
in a different situation for it to be
safe and for it to be viable and there
are sometimes that me just saying just
be out and be proud is dangerous advice
and it's a real shame that that is the
case but
it is in some places in
an increasing number of places it seems
so if you search pride on google at the
moment confetti drops from the top of
the screen and arms holding pride flags
run across the bottom how do you feel
about companies doing that kind of
performative support of the lgbtq
community i mean we all know google
would switch to publicly hating on queer
people if that became the more
profitable pr move
um i'll say what i've always said i
don't
consider it like a big victory or a win
but i do consider it to be a good
barometer because companies like google
like disney
they have
massive marketing departments and part
of their job
is to keep a finger on the pulse on the
cultural pulse
and if these companies
believe that
it is more profitable for them to
support us
than to
condemn us
that means that they believe that's
where society is heading
and i find comfort in that as a
barometer
i'm not gonna massively pet these
companies on the back
um and i'm absolutely gonna call them
out when they undermine
their supposed support like i ended up
having to do with disney
but
i i don't get angry about it
i won't spend money
on it like i have some disney pride
stuff but i didn't buy that i was given
that
um so
you know
i wouldn't encourage you to necessarily
spend money on that kind of stuff any
more than you would spend money on
anything else corporate owned if you can
help it but
i do think there is an there is value in
the fact that it happens at all
it's it is a
it is a barometer that i find hope in
uh my girlfriend is in the final stages
of her transition and i've been thinking
of ways to do something special my mind
keeps going to heavy metal themed party
any suggestions i'm really not in a
position to suggest because i don't i
don't know her if you're asking like for
a good
trans
gift like
i it's
a good gift or party theme is gonna
depend much more on her interest than on
the fact that she's trans so you are
going to be in a much better position to
answer that than i am and also like i i
freeze and i panic trying to think of
part of your gift ideas so i'm not good
for that anyway
would you rather have a replicator or a
holodeck um
oh
probably a replicator i think
tough call though speaking of videos
lantern do you think popular media will
ever get over that you need to forgive
your abusive parents trope hopefully
with time
eventually
but it does pay me when i see it come up
why do you think the disney cartoon
shows are doing so much better than
their animated movies with regards to
queer representation well i kind of
brought this up in the video
uh not this past saturday but the one
before um where i talked about how um
uh you know the pace of representation
is much slower in films and while it's
not the point of that video i do note
that it goes much faster and we're much
more caught up in
tv and or streaming part of the reason
at is that there's way less money spent
on it and there's way less money at
stake and so they don't have to be as
concerned about appealing to as many
people as possible they can allow things
to be niche
in tv and streaming in a way that they
generally don't in movies anymore
because there's almost no such thing as
a mid-budget movie anymore it's either
tent poles or indies with nothing in
between and the in-between is where you
would is where you previously would have
seen you know taking a swing on
something like queer representation so
until it is
at a point where they feel it won't hit
their bottom line on their major tempo
releases yeah
test running it for lack of a better way
to put it in tv makes more business
sense
uh which works uh least well in live
action owl house gravity falls shura or
steven universe
[Music]
i'm going to go with steven universe on
that i think trying to realize
those characters and that world in live
action
like
like even the humans are so
stylized in that
no
no that
none of those would work in live action
that one would work the least
i have nothing to say except i hope
everyone has a happy and safe pride
month i love you uh i love all of y'all
that's lovely
um i used to have a love-hate
relationship with batman loved him as a
kid as i got older i just couldn't stand
how dark
he has a character got not the story so
much as i really hate how batman has
become a perpetual brooder when i feel
that batman the animated series already
had the perfect setup for a modern take
of the character he's a brooder but not
to the point he's depressing he
genuinely wants to help his villains
instead of coming across like he like he
borderline can't stand any of them part
of my issues with modern batman stories
is he doesn't seem to care about helping
his villains or even having any hope of
helping them it's just pessimistic and i
dislike that immensely in batman would
you agree broadly speaking yes i don't
know how bad he is in the comics these
days i've picked up a batman comic in
ages but this is honestly one of the
things that i really really really
really liked
about the recent batman movie that's not
to say that he had he was trying to help
the villains of the story he wasn't
but there
the film was not pointlessly
dark the way i was 99.9 sure it was
going to be
and especially towards the very end it
did something
that i haven't seen a batman like i feel
like i can at least vaguely say this
it's on streaming at this point it has
been for a little bit
there's a note of hope
at the end
not just for batman but like for his
place in the world
that's a that
makes him more than just a vehicle of
vengeance
and actually lets batman be a symbol of
hope not just fear for criminals but
hope for everybody else and i was
shocked that the movie had it and i was
very thankful
thought exercise you have complete
control of dc what what are you changing
why
i don't know
at this point i i honestly don't know
i wouldn't need complete control of dc i
would need complete control of dc and a
time machine
because the thing is
just resetting it back to when i to a
status quo before i think they screwed
everything up that's something dc keeps
doing
that's part of why they keep screwing up
is they keep having writers like it was
better when back at x point let's
rearrange the universe so it's more like
it used to be i
i don't know the dc universe well enough
to know what would be best for it going
forward
and i know i know the dc universe well
enough to know that continually looking
back and resetting back to an older
status quo has done nothing but damaged
it so
um
the stream's going to run a little long
there's been a lot of questions a lot of
the
super chats and a lot of questions on
the discord uh today so we we will run
this stream a little long i'll be back
i'll be back i'm almost done with them
i wish i could go to pride in june but
my local pride festival has been moved
to september october which i'm fine with
because it's hot and humid as hell where
i live in june funny thing vermont has
its pride in september as well although
for kind of a stupid reason it's because
the main pride event happens in
burlington and burlington's a college
town and they moved it to when the
college kids are back
hey
like i still enjoy it but it is weird
that like online all the pride stuff
is in june but then like
actual pride events anywhere near me are
in september
um thoughts on people playing properly
evil pcs in d d it's quite contentious
among dms if done properly i.e in a way
that doesn't impact party cohesion
either in game or irl
um preferably with a solid if screwed up
moral structure affecting uh the pc it
can make for interesting role-playing
experiences
huh
so
i i have not
personally
had a good experience with a dnd
campaign where a character was playing
where another player was playing an evil
character that has not resulted in
campaigns where i had honestly any fun
at all
i think
i think if you have a group
where you have built up a trust
that because here's the main problem
that i have when people play evil ones
in my experience at least
most of the players who play evil
characters in dungeons and dragons
they're
they're players who are trying to win
the game
like
controlling the narrative or beat the dm
or
you know take over the world they're
like they are trying to defeat
basically the other players and the and
the dm
and that's just an unhealthy way to play
the game
it has to be approached if it's gonna
work at all has to be approached as a
communal storytelling exercise
structured as a game
that said if you had a gaming group
where you really had a good rapport and
there was a good level of trust that
everybody was on the same page
at wanting to just tell a good story
maybe
um
maybe
but it's it's something that can go
really wrong also holodecks have
replicators it's how they handle uh and
it's how they're able to handle and
consume stuff oh well i should have said
a holodeck then
that would have been cheating though
that's not in the spirit of the uh of
the question
all right
i am back in the chat and
and there's another super chat supreme
omega on tim drake killing his dad and
trying to kill his love interest uh
spoilers
um this is the whole point of what made
him different from the other robins yeah
that was part of what was fascinating
about tim which was that he didn't have
the same aspect of tragedy that every
other robin had
and it made him different like
now let's make him like everybody else
why
why
i i don't understand dc i really don't
okay i am back in the chat i will give
it a little while longer
since i was i was in the discord for
quite a while
um a show i've been liking is ultraman
on netflix uh which is an animated
version of one of the biggest uh
tokusatsu series in japan highly
recommend it if you want something
different
togasatsu in general isn't really my
genre
so i mean
i don't know i've just got so much stuff
to catch up on have you seen star kids
twisted what did you think of it not
only have i seen it there's a review in
the break room of geeks so you can see
what i thought
i don't know if you agree but i really
hope the uh rtd2 era doesn't bring back
the jerking off of how great humans are
here's the thing
um i'd be very surprised if it did that
because i don't know if you've if you
paid attention to rtd's output since
leaving doctor who
like years and years
and uh
it's a sin
i don't think he's got that optimistic
an outlook of the human race
as he did back when he was show running
doctor who
do i listen to billy eilish a couple of
songs
oof
uh just finished lower deck so
delightful 10d is probably my favorite i
enjoyed the one episode i saw of that
um
[Music]
but i don't have um
paramount plus so
at this point i don't think dc
understands dc
yeah so oh hey meg
good to see you i'm not sure how much
longer the stream is gonna go but thank
you for popping in
it's very telling that the one thing not
shown in the new pinocchio teasers
pinocchio itself it's almost as if even
some mecca knows the cgi will look
creepy as
hell um like i mean it's a standard
teaser thing though to hide
you know your your big selling point
like that so i'd
i it's not necessarily that it might be
um
midnight says human psych yeah i mean
you like even the fourth season the
fourth series of
rtd's doctor who
turn left midnight
i think his his opinion of humanity
was already souring
excuse me captain omni once again my
problem with tim drake currently is they
had him dump stephanie brown for a
random guy since he came out as bi
uh you could just ha
i could just had him come out see like
again i'm not reading the current stuff
so i don't know
how how his um
how his relationship with steph was
doing i don't know how healthy or how
good the stories coming out of it were
and i don't know anything about the guy
he's currently dating i will say
it would have been
kind of commendable
for them to have tim
come out as bi but just continue to date
a girl because you know
being in a same-sex relationship does
not negate your bisexuality
so
you know
that would have been that would have
been kind of cool and then like if there
was ever a natural or more organic
reason to break the two of them up then
you could have had him date a guy that
would have been interesting they didn't
do it but would have been interesting
have you seen the movie everything
everywhere all at once i would like to
very very very much uh i have not as yet
uh jon vinyls in there with the super
chat again live action owl houses cgi
version of king
hello children i am the king of your
nightmares
yeah he would be
although king would kind of be down for
that
ah bow down before me
what why aren't they bowing
uh
saw the chippendale movie today wouldn't
say it's amazing comes off a bit like
first draft but certainly not boring can
be pretty wild i like if i ever
if i ever
have free time again in my life
i'll watch it at some point
i stopped liking tom hanks because he
liked many others
knew about harvey weinstein and did
nothing i
i don't have the spoons to dig into the
extent to which who knew what and who
didn't know what it's a condemnation of
hollywood as a whole that it went on for
as long as it did i am not
i don't have the spoons to start to
parse
specific lane beyond the man himself and
no that's not the same as um
saying people are off the hook i'm just
saying
i have my limits
that's all
question what's up with the damian wayne
hate i don't hate him per se but i do
think he's lesser robin but the
animosity to him uh is like come on
there are some good things okay well
here's the thing you need to understand
about my hatred of damian wayne i have
not read any of the comics in which
damian wayne has appeared i have i only
know damien wayne
through the dc animated movies and he is
the most
insufferable little turd
ever
i
hate him
so much
in those animated movies
he is the worst
ah
and quite possibly worse than he is on
the comic book page
but oh man
ah i'm super jealous because my aunt and
her boyfriend went to the cold play in
concert last week oh that's nice for
them at least
happy pride thank you meg happy pride to
you
uh
captain omni i am gonna wrap up kinda
soon i think uh the relationship with
steph was going fine so it was honestly
way out of left field i'm panned doesn't
mean i immediately had to date everyone
yeah it's it it's uh unfortunately
it it is unfortunately one of those
things that
just happens and and like
here's the thing as irritating as it is
that
things like
dc comics do that have a character come
out as bi and then immediately establish
the same sex relationship to basically
prove it
to a certain extent they do also
i understand why they feel they have to
do that because there is going to be a
section of the audience otherwise who is
going to be saying well
how do we know
and either trying to do trying to erase
the bisexuality
by being like he's not really bi you're
just saying that or
feeling that the um
uh the representation is token because
it's not being backed up
so i do understand
the pressure that
an entity like dc feels from that i wish
they would ignore it
but you know
eternal sailor hufflepuff
do you have another doctor who ranking
plan for the future if so what is it if
not might i suggest a ranking the actual
doctor who logos um i'm actually
planning later this year to start
revisiting uh most of my rankings
because a lot of them are quite old
so i'm gonna start redoing some of those
john
vinyls
cgi hootie
and i make the 2019 jellicles look
attractive and appealing
what do you think of midnight mass have
not seen it
have you seen scream queens nope
do you prefer sweets or salty snacks
salty more often these days
for the most part
no way i made it to your live stream i
can't even i love you so much thank you
maureen it's probably not gonna be going
on too much longer if if we're uh
being honest but i'm glad you got to uh
to pop in
do you think the film edward
ed wood it's problematic with regards to
trans-related stuff bill murray's
character especially i haven't watched
deadwood since the 90s so
i don't
know
i don't remember at all
uh i barely remember the movie i don't i
for completely forgot bill murray was in
it
so i don't i don't have an answer to
that
do you think legends of tomorrow's has
good representation i thought it did
yeah
have i seen an inside job on netflix
noob
have i seen pig nope i don't even
it's like you're just throwing words out
at me now inside job pig midnight mass
you're making some of these up i know
you're not but it's
uh first life i've caught in a long time
i'm very excited for my first pride out
though um
sadly my first pride out although sadly
single unrelated question for you vera
have i read any doctor who books
i have unfortunately the only one i've
read i didn't like i did a review
about two years ago it is on the main
channel
i forget what the name of the book was
the name of the video is doctor who in
the condescending novel i had a lot i
had a lot of issues with that book well
no i had one big issue with that book
but it was big
um
two sentence horror stories that's
surprisingly progressive have not heard
of that
bear's hair is looking luscious oh thank
you meg
uh reminds me the fires of pompeii
uh comes out in july
lovely
i'm a person who believes uh
and the and the good stuff and bad stuff
and everything so like i'll give
hollywood a lot of crap
but i like that la lit up city hall with
batman's logo
went past
on i don't even know about that
uh
[Music]
benedict and martin de cameo sherlock
and john and the great mouse detective
remake
that would be entertaining
now that winnie the pooh is in
the public domain someone's made a
slasher movie yeah i know about that
i'll never watch it but can i be honest
i'm glad it exists
i'm a big supporter of public domain
public domain is wonderful
and we it has been a long time since a
major property slipped into public
domain
so
i'm i'm all for it will it be good
probably not will i watch it hell no but
i'm glad it exists
because
i support public domain
honestly
you know what
i'm going to back up and address the
question that um
got asked earlier
if i had the power to control dc how
would i fix it
you know how i'd fix it
i'd put uh its oldest characters into
the public domain
i would put batman and wonder woman and
superman in the public domain
i'm dead serious
i think that
freeing up those characters to let
anyone with an idea
and before you say oh it'll flood the
market like
yes but the good stuff rises to the top
sherlock holmes is in the public domain
we still get great sherlock holmes stuff
dracula's in the public domain we get
great dracula stuff lovecraft's in the
public domain thank god because we can
have great lovecraftian stuff divorced
from his
racist nonsense
public domain is a wonderful thing
and
i think
it can revitalize a property
especially
when it currently exists in the hand of
a company that don't seem to know what
the hell to do with it
would you end this stream with a
performance of one of the doctor's
speeches as your own incarnation um
i would have had to have planned that in
advance
um i'm gonna be too self-conscious
trying to do that at this point so
i i am i am not i'm not drunk enough
um you can thank sonny bono for the
extension of copyright i can thank a lot
of people mainly disney sonny bono may
have
pushed for it but disney
yeah
thoughts on christopher watkins casting
as the emperor and dune part two oh i
forgot about that
i don't know i didn't think dune was as
good as literally everybody else on the
planet thought it was so i don't know
i was zoning out a little that i heard
dracula hello i'm awake
the children of the night
such sweet music they make
um
what do you think of the doctor as
uh
nyarlotep
i don't understand the question
uh
[Music]
why are characters like squidward and
the grinch considered relatable because
sometimes you're just done
sometimes
you look outside your window and you
just go
nope
and just don't want anything to do with
any of it that's relatable
it just is
nightmares thank you for the super chat
squeaking in at the last minute there
how does one come to terms with being
trans or at least stop the negative
self-talk around it sorry for so serious
a question
um that is
that is a difficult question to answer
especially for me because
i
didn't have personally i didn't have a
lot of
self-hatred self-loathing or talk down
to myself
over the idea that i was trans
the reason my own transition was as slow
as it was was because of a lack of
severe dysphoria
about being masculine so i've talked
about this elsewhere but most trans
people have
a pretty strong
dysphoria
around you know the the body they're
born with
and
they it feels wrong and they push away
from that so hard that in a way that
propels them
in in their trans journey whether they
end up as you know the opposing gender
is non-binary whatever but they are
pushing away from where they started
very hard i never did that
and so my own gender journey has been a
lot slower and a lot more beyond
meandering but not because of any kind
of self-loathing
i mean the main thing honestly is
get a therapist
get a gender affirming therapist someone
who knows about that particular issue
for that uh for you
and who
will work with you through that
that's probably the single biggest
advice i can give
but other than that
here's the one thing that
i i
always say to anyone who's
having trouble
um
embracing themselves
the thing to remember is
that if you are trans
that will never go away
that will never change
and pretending that you aren't
or trying to push it down or trying to
hide it
will only make your life
harder
and less joyous
but the one thing it will absolutely
never do
is change that thing about you or make
it not so
being trans
especially if you don't have a support
system
can be
very
very difficult
but
if that's who you are
you will always
be better
embracing
and living as yourself
than as something you're not
because whatever else you try to be
the fact that you are keeping something
back and suppressing something about
yourself
is always
always going to cloud and dampen and
weigh on
every joy that life would otherwise give
you
being in the closet
is drowning
it is slowly
drowning
and you can't breathe
and
getting your head above water doesn't
suddenly mean that life is wonderful
magical in rainbows but it's where you
have to start
you have to be able to breathe
if anything else is ever going to get
better you have to be able
to be
so
i know it's hard
and it can be hard for a lot of reasons
it can be hard for logistical reasons
it could be hard for
reasons of internalized
confusion or ideas that you haven't been
able to to shake off
there's a lot of reasons why it can be
hard
but the way in which it will be hard
while
being who you are
is less than the way life will be hard
while you try and clamp that down
so
i am going to hope for the best for you
and find a therapist
i mean
it sounds cliche but really really truly
so i hope that helped
uh john vinyls one more super chat have
you watched the country bears from 2002
no no that that one
that one falls under the category of uh
you'd have to pay me to watch it
uh which doctor who logo is your
favorite i do not know i'll probably do
a ranking of those eventually but i
don't know off the top of my head
uh
if daniel radcliffe and elijah would got
together would they do a movie or a tv
show i feel like they do tv together
and i am going to wrap it up in just a
minute i think
a piece of the new 52 i thought was
really good was the earth 2 series i
really liked uh that it takes the og
version of the flashing green lantern
gives them a different spin like i'm
sure there's some good stuff that came
out of the new 52
i never read it
my obs decided to
get stupid on me there for a hot minute
so hopefully i'm still coming through
this is why i stay this right here thank
you
dharma
do i watch any anime series not a
present
denis villeneux should do a metropolis
remake that could be interesting
uh i i am gonna wrap it up uh we've got
we've got a half hour
uh over the normal and yes thank you for
the reminder uh carowind thank you very
much oh goodnight meg
um and yeah i am gonna wrap up now uh so
tomorrow is gonna be twitch it's
probably going to be um
uh
god why can't i think of it secret of
monkey island again i was like i was
looking at
the stuff in my steam library and trying
to think do i have do i have like an
appropriately gay
game to play and i don't so i'll
probably just stick with what i've got
um because a flop-ish cabin boy uh
pirate is about it's probably honestly
the gayest thing i've got so that'll be
uh council of geeks on twitch uh 10 30
a.m eastern daylight time
uh and also tomorrow will be the next
take two doctor who review
it will be on the finale of series 11
battle of renzko ave coloss and saturday
saturday is going to be on the bbc
because of
more stuff
with them
yay
i gotta spend tomorrow
diving into that and throwing a script
together so
but that's what's going on and
thank you
all very much for joining me and
kicking off pride
so the thing that i really want you to
remember
and this is important and i know i say
it a lot but
i really really need you to listen
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you
are
loved
you my friends are the council of geeks
i am just privileged to be the one
running the meetings
so until
next time
this council
is adjourned
my cavity